every time we've talked about primary
challenges to Donald Trump in 2020 I've
been super clear that those challenges
are not going to succeed in the sense of
Donald Trump is going to be the
Republican nominee unless he bails out
but I have said that the primary
challenges could still damage Trump and
even a point or two taken from Trump in
some states is all it would take for an
independent a Republican primary
challenger who chooses to run as an
independent in November of 2020 to take
a state or two from Donald Trump and
push it towards the Democratic
challenger and that could actually turn
the election now clearly the Democratic
I'm sorry the Republican Party is
worried about this because they've now
started canceling primaries and caucuses
to protect Donald Trump and to prevent
anyone from getting any attention or
momentum now Trump loyalists have gotten
into the system in South Carolina Nevada
Arizona and Kansas at minimum and they
are moving forward on canceling
primaries altogether which is not very
democratic wouldn't the right thing to
do be to let the primaries happen let
Republican voters confirm that they want
Trump to be their nominee Trump says he
is 94 percent support from the
Republicans that's not true it's more
like 80 percent but 80 percent is still
more than enough to win primaries except
that that other 20 percent might be
invigorated by those primaries and vote
for those primary challengers in
November if they run as independents or
as write-in candidates in a way that it
could threaten Donald Trump in the
general now the Trump team is saying
this is totally normal
this is fine there are many other
examples in history when primaries have
been canceled when there has been an
incumbent president up for re-election
but that is extremely deceptive because
the primaries that were previously
canceled were almost exclusively
canceled because there were no
challengers so there was no point in
having the primary when only the
incumbent is interested in running this
is a very different situation where you
have multiple primary challengers Joe
Walsh William well there's a third one
that now I'm forgetting and one-fifth of
Republicans disapprove of Donald Trump
so this is a very different scenario now
someone asked Donald Trump on Monday
would he part
stupid in debates against these
challengers and he said quote I don't
know them I would say this they are all
at less than 1% I guess it's a publicity
stunt we just got a little while ago a
poll showing 94% popularity or approval
within the Republican Party so to be
honest I'm not looking to get them any
credibility they have no credibility now
again Trump's wrong it's about 80% of
Republicans that approve of the job he's
doing not 94% but this is how they win
they cancel primaries they gerrymander
they suppress votes by closing down
polling places and purging voter rolls
they have no interest in genuinely
protecting our election systems from
foreign interference and they even
welcome it and then they blame Democrats
of doing all the same things and they
spend millions on real witch hunts like
the election integrity Commission or
whatever it was that it was called which
found nothing
they've been cheating to win for years
it is not going to stop for sure unless
Donald Trump is removed because we'll
have a census in 2020 which will then be
used by these same Republicans to make
it even worse and then it'll get even
uglier and I forgot to mention by the
way gaslighting constantly by demonizing
those evil undocumented immigrants too
it's important not to forget that since
that's a key part of their strategy they
say that they're all for freedom and
democracy as long as it's their
candidate in the way that they want it
and the people voting that they want to
see voting period otherwise freedom and
democracy always take a backseat to
morality or simplicity or expediency or
whatever they can cite at the time to
justify their behavior and we are seeing
it again as the primaries that
Republicans should be holding are
getting cancelled in growing numbers
which we will continue to track not
surprising not surprising but important
to understand that this is happening